foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing a Tom Riddle
horcrux's called Voldemort and the
properties of dark magic more
specifically we're going to be
discussing the ravaging effects that
horcrux has had on Tom Riddle both on
his appearance and on his soul what
truly prompted him to become Voldemort
and what happened to his nose how did he
go from possessing human features to
snake-like features and eventually no
recognizable features at all in the Half
Blood Prince Harry gasps at What Becomes
of the once handsome Tom Riddle entirely
unsure of what he has become Harry let
out a hastily stifled gasp Voldemort had
entered the room his features were not
those that Harry had seen emerge from
the great Stone cauldron almost two
years ago they were not as snake-like
the eyes were not yet Scarlet the face
not yet mask-like and yet he was no
longer handsome Tom Riddle it was as
though his features been burned and
blurred they were waxy and oddly
distorted and at the whites of the eyes
now had a permanently bloody look though
the pupils were not yet the slits that
Harry knew they would become he was
wearing a long black cloak and his face
was as pale as the snow glistening on
his shoulders let's dive into the
destruction of Voldemort before we get
started let's just clear up exactly what
a horcrux is since they're pretty vital
to the rest of the video essentially the
horcrux is an object in which a dark
witch or wizard has imbued part of their
soul the purpose of which is to achieve
immortality well you split your soul you
see and hide part of it an object
outside the body then even if one's
bodies attacked or destroyed one cannot
die for part of the Soul remains
Earthbound and undamaged horcruxes were
considered to be one of the most vile
pieces of dark magic in the very topic
of a horcrux was so taboo that very few
witches and wizards even in the darker
sphere ever even knew of their existence
those who didn't know on the other hand
was smart enough not to discuss them any
further well I guess with the exception
of Horus Slughorn books dedicated to
dark magic like magic most evil
blatantly refused to speak on horcrux's
which should be a testament to just how
bad they were of the horcrux wickedest
of magical inventions we shall not speak
nor give direction in fact the only book
in The Wizarding World with any kind of
proper information on horcruxes was a
book entitled secrets of the darkest art
which was hidden away in Dumbledore's
office the book bound in faded black
leather with accents of purple gave
explicit instructions on how horcruxes
were made how to destroy them and how
creating one can affect you the book
however only discusses the consequences
of creating one horcrux and in this
respect Voldemort took things much
further in this regard Voldemort's
achievements and the various outcomes
good and bad that came from creating
multiple horcruxes were entirely
unprecedented no one could have recently
predicted what horcrux creation would
have done to his body and mind as it had
never been done in this sort of scale
before this brings us to the young
impressionable Tom Riddle the orphan
that tragically never quite stood the
chance in the Half Blood Prince were
taken all the way back to 1938 where we
see a much younger spryer Dumbledore
visiting a troubled looking young boy in
an orphanage who is sitting alone in the
corner of the room other than an
uncomfortable looking expression on his
face no doubt concealing a myriad of
emotions he looked like any other little
boy and would have Blended right in with
the other orphans to any kind of
passerby at least that would be your
first impression but if you stuck around
for any reasonable amount of time you
would have seen first hand that young
Tom Riddle was not like the other
children and I'm not just talking about
the fact that he was magical you see
young Tom loved to torment the other
orphans he was an exceedingly hostile
young boy processing and concealing all
sorts of emotions and in a turmoil that
the rest of the world knew not Tom
himself didn't understand what was wrong
with him but he always knew he was
different and he knew that he needed to
make an impression on the world after
his introduction to Dumbledore he's
invited to Hogwarts School where he
quickly becomes a shining pupil an
innately talented wizard with a passion
for knowledge all driven by The Pursuit
for power after spending some time at
Hogwarts A young Tom Riddle would
eventually come to befriend Professor
Horace Slughorn riddles then potions
Professor Slughorn had a tendency to
choose favorites from his classes get a
Keen Eye for identifying if someone
would go on to achieve greatness in some
capacity and would always take great
pride in their accomplishments usually
at least if you were close with sakhorn
he would tell you anything and that's
probably why on one occasion after just
the right amount of manipulation and
flattery from Riddle he provided him
with pivotal information on horcrux's
the very form of magic that was
instrumental involved motorized to power
this was the beginning of the end for
riddle as from this point onward he now
possessed the necessary information to
curse his soul mind and body all in the
needless pursuit of Power with this new
information riddle embarked on his
journey of creating horcruxes and from
that moment on he started to dehumanize
himself both physically and mentally
gradually slipping and moving even
further away from the man that he once
was because of his horcruxes Voldemort
couldn't die he was Tethered to the
world through these objects but that
certainly didn't mean that Voldemort was
truly alive he had a cursed existence I
believe that Voldemort is now so
immersed in evil and these crucial parts
of himself have been detached for so
long he does not feel as we do so what
exactly does dark magic do to you why
does it change your appearance what
happened to Voldemort well in essence
Voldemort's appearance changed because
of the actions that he undertook every
time he murdered someone every time he
cast unforgivable curses and every time
he created a horcrux he tore his soul
apart even further which made him become
less human and more Monster it wasn't
just horcrux as it altered Tom Riddle it
was a combination of everything living
an evil existence but nothing but the
wrong intentions Voldemort didn't turn
into the monster that he was overnight
at least not physically it was a gradual
process that occurred over years
performing dark Deeds for example there
is a moment where Dumbledore shows Harry
a memory of Voldemort after he
resurfaced this was after he disappeared
for 10 years he came back to Hogwarts to
hide the Ravenclaw horcrux and to ask
Dumbledore who was newly appointed as
Headmaster for the defense against the
dark arts position at this point it's
made clear that Tom Riddle's appearance
had drastically changed no it wasn't
white skinned with no nose but he wasn't
a handsome boy that he once was he'd
clearly begun to spiral down the Dark
Descent into the unnatural Horrors that
dark magic can bring basically with each
horcrux that he created Voldemort became
paler more snake-like and less human
Dumbledore felt that one of the main
contributing factors in the degradation
of appearance with the damage that he
had done to his soul yet it fitted Lord
Voldemort had seemed to grow less human
with the passing years and the
transformation he had undergone seemed
to me to be only explicable if his soul
was mutilated beyond the Realms of what
we might call usual evil and we see a
perfect example of this in the afterlife
after Harry's encounter with Voldemort
in the Forbidden Forest Harry turned
slowly on the spot his surroundings
seemed to invent themselves before his
eyes he had spotted the thing that was
making the noises it had the form of a
small naked child curled on the ground
its skin raw and rough flayed looking
and it lay shuddering under a seat where
it had been left unwanted staffed out of
sight struggling for breath Harry was
met with the last piece of soul that
Voldemort possessed a damaged tormented
representation of what dark magic can do
to a person Voldemort lived a cursed
life where he would routinely rep his
own soul apart in pursuit of immortality
and such acts come at a great cost the
wriggling child squirming along the
floor was all that was left of
Voldemort's soul in conclusion there's
no one spell or one action that one can
take in order to change their appearance
in the way that Voldemort did it takes a
lifetime of dedication to dark arts and
dark Deeds that's the only way one can
possibly expect to recreate the
unprecedented Horrors achieved by Lord
Voldemort and that's it for this video
If you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember for in dreams
we enter a world that is entirely our
own